she's the most talented boy in the world
Megan Fox deactivates her Instagram
account after hinting at a split with
Machine Gun Kelly but we're hearing the
couples seemed fine while partying every
night together during Super Bowl weekend
[Music]
it started when equal eyed fans noticed
the actress unfollowed her fiance on
Instagram then a suggestive caption on
this mirror selfie you can taste the
dishonesty it's all over your breath
yeah if that sounds familiar it's from
Beyonce's song Pray you catch me
[Music]
wanna stay it's all over your breath
Megan caps this off by deactivating her
account meanwhile
[Music]
oh yes this is when I got electrocuted
MGK telling ET about his shocking
performance the night before kickoff
yeah I kept stepping on a certain part
of the stage every time the sparklers or
the smoke would go off and I kept
feeling my whole body like Joe I wish I
had that going through my body all the
time I'd have a good hair day a lot our
eyewitness who was in the audience says
the 32 year old seemed a bit off and
energy was low unlike the couple's
intense romance where arguments are
common according to ET Source but always
ends with making up
maybe some things to keep in mind The
Insider adds Megan is known to troll her
fans for attention during the couple's
off times Well nothing seemed off
Grammy's weekend don't trip on wins or
losses when Megan supported MGK after he
lost telling him on the gram you have
handled this process with Grace and
maturity that I haven't seen from you
before and I'm so proud of you the wind
is being here the wind is the journey EC
caught up with MGK on the Grammys red
carpet shortly after he learned he lost
it was more cathartic and more
um
I learned a bigger lesson in the
45-minute car ride that I had on the way
here than I think I've learned in 30
years and like that was
it's the beginning of my uh
my journey of self-worth
[Music]